mama papa did you see the cuny groceries
i got nope these are special groceries
oh yeah of course you could see
this show monkey what's in here oh this
is for you monkey oh you see it
it's a big candy do you see it no it's
right there
look it's right here look
oh yeah okay let's look you want some
mmm
this is delicious
do you want some water
i was looking for that cheese platter
that's already pre uh prepackaged but
they didn't have it but you want me to
show you something really cool you did
great so we're about to go out into the
nature
and just have a cuny
cuny family day together grill up some
burgers and just relax and just veg out
and look at this
isn't this cool they have a whole uh
hamburger of fixings yes you just got
two of them you just got two of them you
got everything and a thing i don't have
to cut or nothing no prep
so cool huh yeah what was it like ten
dollars per
like three bucks 350 or something we got
burger buns
i got this look monkey got your favorite
watermelon
and then i got some patties
i'm gonna put it all in here this is
perfect cute
perfect
yeah i got you uh some pita and some
hummus i got your guacamole and some
chips all right why why the guacamole
dude you look guacamole
guacamole
you look like wood
and then i got some extra firewood it's
already in the back of the truck what we
gotta go to aria and get some lounge
chairs the ones that lean back oh okay
let's go yeah
and then we're gonna set up that little
bonfire thing
and have a cuny family day out in the
woods and just relax
no screens no nothing and have a good
time
this is one of my favorite
and least favorite parts
about going outdoors is the packing my
favorite because i love seeing
everything organized
and all the good time that we're gonna
have and i love like messing with gear
my least favorite is the exact same
thing i hate packing
which is why i love my drawer system in
my truck because i could just leave a
bunch of the stuff i'm gonna take
anyways in there
um so it's weird yeah i also i like
packing
but that's why also i think like day
camping is so fun because i don't have
to prep for so many days ahead you know
when you're like doing like a three-day
trip you got to plan every meal so okay
breakfast what is that gonna be okay
lunch is gonna be sandwiches nights beef
stew omelet in the morning and then also
you have to share all the ingredients
because you don't want to over pack you
know so you try to find all these
ingredients that all fit and work
together okay cool tomatoes i can use
over three four different dishes squash
i can over three four different dishes
and it takes a lot of brain power and so
by the time you're done packing you're
just tired this is really easy put
everything in here ready to go and i
have a visitor
cuny guy
hey where'd he go
hey there he is
what's that duty a big bucket
with all kinds of toys in there
fidget toy that's awesome
so everything is packed ready to go it's
my favorite part because it looks nice
and clean and organized bonfire
cooler chairs we need a couple more
campfire
my cooking loadout and then also
a rinse kit because you never know you
always have water and remember from a
few months ago when i was organizing the
garage
and i had all the
the camping stuff all stored away it was
so easy to load the cook stuff because
it was right here
remember i had these containers so this
is like if i'm going to stay overnight i
have lanterns mosquito repellent all
that stuff
sleeping bags
um tent mattress
uh blankets and that would be my cookout
section and the rinse kit down here so
this is my whole
outdoorsy section so it's easy just pull
that out put in the back of the truck
now we're ready to go
so papa didn't get this but we were all
napping minus pop obviously in the car i
was not paying too you didn't see
well how would i see if you're napping
not true um and then when i woke up
we were in like this desert winter
wonderland
so we found this like yup
yup
this is a regular mountain now with a
little bit of snow on that yeah good eye
dude um
so we just found like this random little
trail off of like the main road
saw this van and they're probably like
oh god we're trying to f out here but
look here you are
um
so we're just following it now
well i love this i love going
off-roading and then just kind of like
exploring whoa
and seeing cool stuff oh a lot of people
have this idea these locals know what's
up oh my god i got a propane tank you
know his girl's legit
yeah well then he got a little trash bag
right there what a clean oh these guys
might be staying overnight huh yeah
maybe oh got a nice little
little wrap to their truck
but we're over here
trying to make our way to our little
spot this is cool
this is really cool
this is fun right yeah when i'm like
away from everything and everybody this
is what i'm talking about we could be
right there if it gets windy those
little crevices like that it helps block
the wind okay boy scout is that what you
learned
no it's just common sense oh yeah yeah
it's dog people you're right all right
so taika are you warm yeah you feel good
buddy
that's poop i think it's okay sure
yeah
okay look at our little stations already
getting set up papa's about to set up um
lunch yeah he enticed taika with a
little shovel action look look how
excited papaya is
i love this look at this face this man
is so happy this is like the military
life
without the military and ad family yeah
and hearts
and what part of it is military besides
the outdoor just the outdoors and the
self uh sustaining abilities i see
okay so now taika and i where are we
going monkey
we're gonna go explore the shovel yeah
so normally i'd like to stay and help
peppa set up but he's having so much fun
he's like no i got it you guys go do it
i'll set everything up
which i'm not mad at so ty and i are
going to go find trash so that we can go
burn it
ready that was water yeah
papa got a cutie little grill cute
little girl i got this this is so cheap
you can get it anywhere um but it folds
out and this thing actually works by
itself if you just set up logs on the
floor yeah it doesn't stand right and it
just folds out so this is my one of my
favorite go-to like portable grilles but
this thing also fits perfectly on this
uh bottom fryer thing look it won't
slide off so
hell yeah our burger's on it these bombs
look at cuny and mama bear and taika
they went all the way over there
just exploring it's my favorite
watching them just walk around and
explore
and they left the bucket there
i know you don't i know you don't look
at this papa
is killing it look at that
okay so let me translate for you guys
well we're dead over there okay so when
tyke and i were exploring
just now uh we saw that a family left
the memorial or i think they buried
their puppy out here actually and have a
little memorial for him so um i'll show
you guys in a little bit once we're done
eating wow this looks fancy
whoa
oh god i'm like tooting my own horn
but man this burger
came out really good
mm-hmm
was that bomb was it available
i mean
you're bringing bomb into the
conversation
yeah
it's definitely not bomb oh man but he's
really good mine's really good
you're just excited you big bozo no i
think it was really good trust me that's
really good it's the best ball you're
so we just finished our lunch
tech is looking like a cool guy let me
see cool guy
hey can you tell me why you're not
supposed to drink a lot of soda
because you burped a lot yeah why do you
look so cool
dude and he got rainbow candy
he was like mom i have to go pee i'm
like okay let's go but i want to pee on
the snow
did you have fun peeing on the snow yeah
yeah
i kept going yeah baby
he uses the word
baby at the most perfect time especially
when i don't expect it forget to go pee
goes yeah baby oh my god damn it
so yeah now we're gonna go and explore
look at papa
i'm gonna fight the bad guys
hey
gotta take advantage of the open carry
state you know what i mean why it's so
funny you don't even know what that
means it's open carry you say it's open
carry stay baby it's only kids day baby
man so we are just walking and walking i
think we've walked
man a long way
a really long way
look how long we've walked
it actually looks pretty far on camera
i could throw a rock and hit it without
missing for sure okay so i wanted to
show pop-up and obviously you guys um
the little grave that that
the the
parents left for the little pop-up it's
so
cute
you see it oh there it is
oh how cute
you got baby
[Music]
i used to surf that's so cuny little
surfer dude yeah
oh
you might look like a mama
that's cuny boy he wouldn't surf mommy
had love what a badass dog man i bet
they're devastated look how cool this
guy is oh that jar has a solar panel on
it that means that didn't i just say
that you didn't say that i thought i
said that oh maybe maybe maybe it lights
up that cross at night yeah i don't know
what that is something shirt oh that
might be his favorite shirt oh buddy
i love you
the safari of noise is the reason the
wolf looks dead i didn't say wolf wolf
what are you talking about you're making
stuff up hey
[Music]
hey be respectful don't mess with this
why are you messing with us
no that's because you have to let it
rest in your home what if i go and i put
my dirty boots on your bed
that's messed up isn't it
like poop poop oh i farted sorry
i was kidding
oh poop dog
okay taika what do you need
[Music]
my poop up on the ground
and then i know
that
i don't know single word that he said he
pooped on the ground and he used to
struggle to dig up dig over it oh that's
so nice
so that was definitely tiger's first
i think outdoor like camping
camping pooping incident
and it's cuny because
it's cool to have him start at such a
young age he's four and so we're
teaching taika that you got to return
everything back to nature
so if you poop you got to dig a big hole
put the poop in it cover it up and
hopefully my shovel doesn't have baby
[ __ ] on it because
i don't want a stinky shovel in my car
here tell people what you just did right
now
oh that's so nice of you now you're
going to feed the mother nature he was
so funny he's grabbing and he's going
i can't believe i'm about to dig
let's see big funny guy
no don't hit it because you're going to
smash the poop out of there that's it
let's just bury the poop and pretend it
never happened let's go let's go there's
no poop one there is there go put some
snow on it yeah thank you please oh
jesus rapey baby poop no not snow on
that
oh fine you blessed it there was no poop
on your shovel promise yeah why would i
why would i lie thank god
i just threw it on top and then i
patted it down
okay we're done you poop monster
toothpaste
hey hey hey you're about to get the you
just shoveled your poop
okay so i missed most of this but we got
firewood out of here
you dug a hole yup you put it in the
hole and water it you watered it sprayed
it down real quick and now you put the
dirt back on top and now tech is going
to spray it again yep
and why are we doing this tycho do you
know why we're doing this
safety and what happens
yeah we don't want accidental fires yeah
there's a little bit of smoke still
that means there's still a little bit of
fire underneath there that's why it's
good to have mud
yeah not yet don't wet it
it's good to have mud and dirt
so that way we don't have any forest
fires
okay go
and then this one this one here too
good job okay let me see
okay that's it
[Music]
so now we are just off-roading a bit
driving around
it has this really cool trail already
set where other trucks come
it's not too bumpy but it's like bumpy
enough for you to make you feel like
you're out in the wilderness which
clearly we are
and this guy's providing all the sound
the sound effects
go do it all of a sudden now
there we go
ladies and gentlemen
i don't know how we stumbled upon this
game but it's pretty fun
and it first started off with
uh miles morales flying through the air
so we're playing catch
except i'm throwing it up there and he
throws it back down
watch check it out are you ready
you're a gumdrop
[Music]
okay ready
all right here it comes
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
so marber is really smart
because today's a holiday
and marber uh saw it coming so she was
like hey you know what we should
probably get some food
because
a lot of postmates aren't going to be
open you know our restaurants and stuff
like that
and i'm like good idea so we got one of
our favorite
the pasta from costco and it's so easy
to store we stored it in our freezer for
about a week or two
and then we just thought it out
overnight and then we threw it in the
oven and it came out really really good
that's what we're gonna have
for dinner look at that
i already uh brought tycoos out cause
he's so scared of the heat so i have to
let it air out still kind of warm
and i might serve myself a plate but
honestly
if you get it for like a party and then
you serve it
people will be amazing but did you make
that and you just go
you got
we all took a shower whoa that's a deep
voice
we all took a shower
and now it's time for us to wrap up the
night
and ma bear has been crushing it
with doing the laundry no one beats
doing the laundry room mama
are you hiding something nope
hmm
have you seen taika
who
taika
i don't think i know who that is what's
in
there okay all your clothes
thank you you folded way better than i
did so you i think you should do it i
know you're so right thank you
let's see if there's a no there's
nothing there's nothing huh no
hey
all right
well i guess we're gonna have to say
good night
without knowing where
taika is
taika i don't think i've heard of it so
all right dude we gotta go to sleep all
right all right good night everyone good
night
[Laughter]